all right let's go back to the phones at
617-830-4750
and see what is on people's minds a lot
going on
uh we will next try our caller from the
713 area code who's calling today from
713 where are you calling from
hello david this is james i'm from
houston texas
what's going on james
uh yeah so to preface this i'm kind of
uh in between
the two third parties i'm kind of the
undecided between the green party
hawkins and the libertarian party and
this pick
like i have very progressive social
views and things like that as well as
economic views
but this pick for kamala harris just
really
i was i was kind of on the biden train
but now i'm
i'm really gonna i'm really convinced i
have to vote for hawkins
he's also got a black running mate
angela walker but i just don't think
kamala harris is
the right pick she's she feels like such
a few to the african-american community
as well
okay so um what so so what can you say
more about that what was what is it
exactly
your her record as california attorney
general is what's concerning you that's
why you might not vote for biden harris
yeah i mean i i'm obviously i i don't
like trump
really i don't even like biden that much
but just her record
and also i was kind of on the tulsi
i was kind of a big supporter supporter
of tulsi and the only thing that
brought kamala harris kind of back into
the spotlight
was joe biden kind of defending her and
then
saying that he will uh keep her as a
pick for his vp okay but does that have
anything to do with why you would or
wouldn't vote for
for them
yeah i just i just don't think it's a
of it's not she's she's a she's a
warhawk she's a
drug warrior and i don't think any of
this system that was
made and accelerated in the 90s under
the presidency of bill clinton
really needs to continue anymore and has
she said that it would continue
well i mean i just don't i mean bull
biden doesn't want to legalize marijuana
that's true no he doesn't
i just don't feel that a four four or
12 years of biden at harris i'm not
saying it's going to
be that way but i just don't feel like
stuff is going to change as much
socially on these on these economic
issues as well because this
just well hold on a second let's back up
hold on but also because of the war on
truck
i have to stop you there oh if anything
over the last
three weeks the divide on economy
remember
it's biden versus trump right so kamala
harris's economic ideas from
from three years ago are not what is
going to determine
what the next four look like a huge
chasm or chasm has opened up
between biden and trump on economic
policy i mean trump wants to
cut the payroll tax which funds social
security
whereas biden wants to uncap it above
400 000
that that that's like 99 to 1 difference
uh on capital gains trump wants to cut
capital gains
biden wants to tax capital gains as
ordinary income
i mean i could go on but on economic
policy
you know whatever your views are on
harris we there is
nothing similar about biden and trump on
that issue at this point and to say
there is is very deceptive
oh i totally support biden on the
economic issues it's just the social
issues
okay well i mean let me ask you this
let's just bottom line bottom line
do you prefer biden or trump to be
president if it's going to be one of the
two because it is going to be one of the
two who do you prefer oh definitely
biden
okay so then maybe vote for biden
okay yeah i mean i'll still i'll still
do a little bit of research but thanks
for thanks for answering my call david
okay thank you i appreciate
it thank you very much